elle ouvre à nouveau la saison isabelle
olivier partage pour la deuxième année
son amour pour les potes à watteau me
l'harpiste poursuit l'exploration de son
instrument dans une nouvelle
collaboration avec le chorégraphe et
radiant isabelle poursuit avec une
deuxième année de résidence
c'est une résidence de compositrice
soutenu par le ministère de la culture
et la sacem et là il se serait une
création qui ira au delà de la rencontre
du jazz et du hip hop
puisque la création intégrera notamment
le cirque également le cirque aérien des
femmes à nouveau très présente dans la
programmation la salle guyancourt toise
continue son axe au sein du matrimoine
cet héritage culturel féminin avec deux
créations théâtrales la folle enchère un
texte de madame ullrich qui sera monté
par aurore et 20 et là c'est une comédie
xviie siècle dans la veine des comédies
de molière
une comédie très très enlevé une comédie
je dirais même très pop dans son
traitement très joyeuse à très
irrévérencieuse et une tragédie les
amazones dannemarie du bocage une
tragédie du xviiie siècle en alexandrins
monté par mylène bonnet des créations la
ferme de bel ébat en propose 23
bien sûr que les artistes ont besoin des
théâtres mais un théâtre sans artiste ça
n'existe pas c'est comme un théâtre sans
spectateurs on a besoin des deux donc il
faut il faut qu'on leur accorde notre
confiance au moment où ils en ont le
plus besoin du théâtre du cirque un bal
de la musique
la ferme de bel ébat propose aussi une
réflexion autour de la mémoire
cinquante sept spectacles pour s'envoler
il avait emmené
monsieur toujours blues des paysans
bessines où jamais il ne pleut ou l'on
ne sait rien de toner
[Musique]